hey guys it's justine and welcome to my
garage we are turning this thing into an
at-home gym first up and most
importantly this is the nordic track
rower 900 a huge thank you to
nordictrack for sponsoring this video i
have been such a huge fan of theirs for
a really long time my sister also
recently just got one of their
treadmills and after running on that it
was like my entire life
just changed in an instant i'll talk to
you guys more about all of the
incredible features that not only the
tread has
but the rower and also their all digital
lab and next up we have this
we have got some mats because one of the
things that i haven't been able to do in
over a year
is train jiu-jitsu so i decided to bring
jiu-jitsu to my garage and force my
sister
to start training with me i'm also
forcing her to help me
set up i also forced her to help me
clean out the garage
i ordered her dinner i offered her money
but she turned down
so so let's unbox these mats
and then set up the rower and get to
fitness
here they are oh these are so nice
i'm so excited yeah put that away put
this away
like they're happy but they're not that
they're heavy
[Music]
step one is complete looks good do you
want to take a little nap
flip yet what if i broke your arm yeah
uh training will start
on monday of next week okay
we gotta snip the rover now yes thank
you okay
[Music]
wow
oh the seat oh nice very important part
oh our hardware kit
smell it learn about it maddie very
important directions
but there's also an app built built so
they have a partnership with built
which i've actually never heard about
until i was putting my tread together i
already have it up so this is the rw 900
rower
yes and it will basically give you a
step by step it says two people 30
minutes 24 steps and it'll walk you
through each step
here we go let's do it
[Music]
teamwork makes the dream work
do we do it yeah oh my gosh
it works oh it moves no way
look at this i'll be able to do workouts
over here yeah
that's nice that's cool oh my gosh this
is incredible
i'm so excited so time to get started
we're at the welcome screen i'm going to
connect to wi-fi and get this all set up
they also have heart rate monitors which
are definitely something that i
recommend if you are doing any types of
workouts because when you are doing a
workout like you really want to be able
to monitor your heart and know if you're
actually making progress
and how you're progressing so we're
about to start this up i'm going to put
this on and i'm going to do one of my
first classes this will automatically
adjust
the resistance to go along with what the
trainer is doing
so i won't have to make any changes at
all i can just focus on my workout
this is adjustable depending upon
your foot size let's go time to row
there's so many different options of
places that you can row you can
basically row
all around the world i mean there's so
many different options i can also do
ones in the studio but i think i need to
get outside
and go to portugal this looks like an
easy one and since i'm a beginner rower
we need an easy one so the resistance
doesn't look too difficult
let's go for a row
over here is our resistance and i have
it set so that it will automatically be
adjusted
to go with alex's road let's just
sit with our legs straight this feels
nice
this is hard work
[Music]
oh man the resistance just automatically
changed
from a six to an eight and i feel it
all right i'm gonna turn this down a
little i still feel like i'm here
i'm gonna go back to six i appreciate
him automatically changing
i'm not ready
there it is we did it
[Music]
easy recovery that was an easy class
wow i have a lot to work up to but this
was
incredible i loved my first row and now
what i'm gonna do is maybe
a little yoga a little stretching they
also have other types of classes like
strength classes
yoga classes so even if you don't have a
piece of equipment like this you can
still take advantage of some of their
classes
that was a workout wow so obviously this
is a rower and there are rolling classes
but there's so many other class options
on here there's yoga there's strength
training now i could
just work out like this but what i can
do is i can just lift this up
where do i want it to go
like i can put it wherever i want one of
the things that i love about this
is you can fold it up so if you don't
have a lot of space
in your room you can just fold this up
and
tuck it away i mean it's still pretty
big but considering
that you can fold this up quite small
i'm impressed
i mean look at this
small there's even a little clip to keep
it
nice and sturdy look at that that's
perfect
and it's nice because i can just go like
this and i am ready
to train here on the mats let's maybe
end this
day with a little bit of yoga let's do
let's do this nice stretch in st george
utah
oh look at this this is so pretty
oh my gosh look where she's at i want to
be there
these cool drone shots hey what's up i'm
ashley falconer and welcome to this
acting recovery
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching and
again a huge thank you to northern track
for sponsoring this video i'm so excited
to start integrating rowing into my
workouts even if you aren't able to fit
equipment into your home or your
apartment
i love that ifit has so many different
classes that you're able to still do
that is available online for
subscription as well happy 2021 i would
love to know what your fitness goals are
for the new year i know at the beginning
of the new year everybody likes to start
doing their new year's resolutions so
i'd love to hear from you guys
what are yours leave them in the
comments below and i will see you guys
in my next video
[Music]
bye
you